protect your bubble calm proud sponsors
of swipe on Sky News you're watching
flight on the show this week
robotic arms - augmented reality we take
a glimpse at the future of education at
eat eater but a nutritionist in your
pocket with a world first out and we're
chasing shadows in this week's games
review hello and welcome to swipe this
week we're at bet 15 a major event where
education means technology
now if computer science at school was a
bit of a dry experience for you I mean
for me it was all about saving pie
charts onto floppy disk it's not like
that anymore though these days have
tablets with numerous apps and even 3d
printers in their classrooms that's just
a doll
as well when you hear the words computer
programming this might not be the first
thing you think of by using a coding
language called fuse basic and a
Raspberry Pi computer these kids have
learned how to control a robotic arm
this might look like a game but it's
been designed for a good reason
Britain needs programmers and technology
like this could help to inspire the next
generation it's a very engaging device
it's ideal for children they can control
a robot arm that that's a lot of fun but
actually the message behind it is we can
control a robot arm which is a very
complex device using very simple basic
commands traditional classroom setups
are also changing wise floors been
designed to get kids away from the
computer screen and make lessons more
interactive by using their feet they're
able to control the game being played
out on the mat but could augment it
reality like this ever replace desktop
learning mixed economies of learning
work best where children are given
opportunities to work with text books
without where they're active whether in
situations where they're moving the
better their learning is the more rich
and diverse and interesting that is the
more they're engaged and the more
interest if they become schools now have
access to a huge range of teaching aids
so choosing the right option is crucial
and as the technology evolves teachers
have to move with it recent research
showed that 130,000 English primary
school teachers don't feel confident
enough to teach their pupils how to code
and out of 250 teachers 73% said they
don't feel they've been given the right
resources so what's the government doing
to help teachers get up to speed we are
partnering with organizations in order
to help with that teacher training
and to really go in and help teacher
their professional development so they
continue to have the skills so that they
are able to
the most modern technologies having
access to different teaching methods can
only be a good thing but relying solely
on technology is unlikely to be the
answer well sergeant scannings well
along with plenty of education
technology here at bat 15 there are also
some parental communication systems and
one man we didn't expect to see here is
their Sir Bob Geldof Bob hello thanks
for joining us and tell me about group
call and the system that you're here
promoting today
well group paulus a company that myself
and my mates here started a few years
back and it was because them you know
all my girls were going to school I've
suddenly become freed this year because
the last one left school so free free at
last you know oh I don't have to go away
every August now I go away any time so
he came with the idea of this mass
texting and as you can see from I'm
extremely high tech but the one thing I
do receive his text you know because the
girls have bunch of different schools I
was you know I wanted to know they got
there I was oh they were saying I want
to know what was going on from that
consist huge thing which works within
the education system and glues it
together and then moves outside that
links parents teachers and students
I mean the technology that we have is is
really evolving to solve a two-way
conversation with parents what do you
say to critics who believe that there
are too many shiny gadgets being put in
schools now then actually the money
should be better spent on teachers wages
what is clear is that the ability of
this thing to extend learning into the
poorer parts of the world the other
developed world is essential
particularly for girls and you know
girls are often as we've seen you know
horrendously with those you know then
you're turning on two thirds of the
world and the difference it makes
populations crash economies grow that's
for sure would that happen through the
old pen and pencil method you know of
school learning no do you still need
teachers yes why to point out what's
important in what you can show later on
we'll review the latest mobile games
including the daring sheep with a crafty
escape plan but first his roundup of
some of this week's other techniques
Microsoft has unveiled glasses that
overlay Holograms on the real world as
the company launched its Windows 10
operating system the hololens lets
wearers interact with virtual objects
although it's not yet clear when it'll
go on sale still struggling to stick to
that healthy eating New Year's
resolution a new app called happy coach
lets you take pictures of your meals and
send them live to real nutrition experts
to get approval or advice it'll be
available for pre-order next month and
London has held its first mobile games
week the event included all sorts from
networking activities to award
ceremonies with the goal of boosting
investment in the Capitals mobile games
sector
and in honor of London's first mobile
games week we decided to check out a few
new games for your mobile and tablets is
Lucy shadow motsek is this great iPhone
game is a great idea
first of all it's sort of it's basically
the mobile version of making shadow
puppets with your hands and what it does
is it presents this really abstract
model I say it's not very difficult but
it actually kind of is is you have to
move this abstract model until it casts
a recognizable shadow and it sounds easy
but these models are quite intricate and
sometimes you really can't tell what
it's supposed to be and you know they'll
be things from like fish and rabbits you
know quick easy things to you know
people doing to dough and kettles so
there's a big wide range and it's just
quite nice it's quite a relaxing game
the music's very good and so it's nice
just to wile away you know car journey
just trying to figure out what exactly
that shape is meant to eat that's very
nice it's adventure time game wizard is
you know piggybacking off the popularity
of the kids cartoon so there's a lot of
different levels to it there there's the
adventure mode kind of game where you
play as the two main characters Finn and
Jake and it's a side-scrolling kind of
platformer you've got a sword jump on
platforms and things and it's it's got
weird al' in it you know as the has the
evil antagonist and you know it's all
fully voiced and wings I mean drawing a
video game so the antagonist you you've
somehow managed to grab his power in
that you can make your own games we can
do it in two different ways so you can
only use the in-game level builder which
is quite nice very intuitive very very
simple to use but as this is game for
kids so it's quite nice and it can build
their own levels what you can also do is
you can draw them and then use your use
your phone or iPad or anything just scan
them in and it'll make them in the game
and then you can edit them in there so
it's both a game and a game builder do
either of my game Wizards need a pencil
oh I do okay first you need to shave
Lucas is from British legends team17
so it was a PC game came to consoles and
now it's on mobiles and it's kind of
like lemmings but with a really dark
kind of Tim Burton twist
so you're shepherding sheep from the
startup level to the end and to get over
gaps and things you have to give them
powers like the ability to jump or
become a super sheep and fly walls and
things but the thing is if you fail or
you miscalculate or you give the Sheep
the wrong you know the wrong power at
the wrong time they will die horribly
it's a great game it's fun it is just
like playing lemmings it's very fun
there's a lot of content in there
there's a lot of different powers you
give the sheep but it's so gruesome at
the same time
well that's it for this week but don't
forget you can stay up to date with all
the latest tech stories kinda use the
iPad our smartphone apps can use calm
and though YouTube channel see you again
next time bye bye
protect your bubble calm proud sponsors
of swipe on Sky News